the national death toll from the virus
has risen sharply in part because of how
victims are counted that number is now
up to around 31,000 that includes more
than 4,000 New Yorkers who were never
tested but did show symptoms meanwhile
some Americans including these
protesters in Lansing Michigan are
losing patience with social distancing
in New York the rules are actually
getting stricter our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is in New
York City David what exactly is changing
we have to wear masks now Anthony
especially when you walk into food
Mart's like the one behind me the
governor's order will say if you cannot
maintain a social distance you are
required to wear masks and other cities
are doing this like Los Angeles speaking
of LA the mayor actually said that he
could ban it is likely he will ban all
large gatherings such as concerts and
sporting events through 2021 back here
in New York the governor is saying look
the latest tool I have to control the
spread of the virus is the masks but the
tool the governor needs even more than
that and you're gonna hear it again
widespread testing we cannot do it
without federal support Governor Andrew
Cuomo insists that large-scale testing
in a state the size of New York is not
possible without the help of Washington
we've only been 500,000 tests you're
talking about a state with 19 million
people but there is outrage bubbling
elsewhere in the country over stay at
home orders this shutdown has become one
of total insanity
that's the Mayor of Las Vegas Carolyn
Goodman pointing out that Nevada's death
toll has been less than half of one
percent of the population she's
demanding an end to the state's lockdown
it makes no sense for heaven's sakes for
being closed is killing us already
protests in Michigan over the governor
strict isolation orders clogged streets
on Wednesday the governor says she
understands people are angry I just urge
you don't put yourself at risk and don't
put others at risk either meanwhile
Smithfield Foods in South Dakota is
reportedly the biggest kovat night
hot spot in the country with 644 cases
coming from a now closed pork processing
plant the US Secretary of Agriculture
sonny Perdue tweeted Wednesday that he
is doing everything he can to get the
plant back open and minimize disruptions
to the nation's food supply in Colorado
21 year old Cody Lister is the youngest
person to die from corona virus in the
state you got up one morning and he had
to go to school you had to go to Grand
Junction Grand Junction is four hours
from where we are and that is when we
actually called for the union within one
hour of arriving at the hospital he was
on a ventilator and eight days later he
was gone in Florida Gerald and Arlene
Polinsky died the way they lived
together both infected with the disease
they wound up at the same hospital their
son-in-law David wrote on Facebook in a
scene befitting a story tale ending as
his body was being moved out of the room
the nurses told us that she noticed and
she said together Jerry and then she was
gone
the Polinski x' were married for 64
years back in Colorado where Cody died
we talk about the randomness of this
virus his father had coronavirus his
mother had the symptoms and she's a
diabetic both of them recovered without
ever needing to go to the hospital yet
Cody died at 21 years old Toby
[Music]
David you can understand people's
frustrations economically but at the
same time as you remind us there is a
major health threat here as well David
thank you very much